how come you're not at your brother's
wedding today
you fell asleep
you fell asleep you said
today's your brother's big day
well that was awkward ben affleck's
little brother casey was caught in los
angeles trying to explain why he was
missing on the day of his big bro's
wedding to jennifer lopez in georgia
we're trying to get some can you see if
we can get in the papers because i'm
trying to get could i could i listen and
according to tmz benzack's jennifer
garner was spotted grocery shopping in
west virginia over the weekend
clearly not in attendance for ben's
nuptials
ben affleck and jennifer lopez
officially said i do for the second time
at his estate in riceboro georgia on
saturday
it's just a dream come true following
the couple's intimate las vegas wedding
in july the three-day event all went
down in front of their closest family
and friends
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time but with ben's mom christopher
ann bolt being in attendance it's
surprising that casey his only sibling
was m.i.a what's up casey
how you doing today i'm doing well man
please don't video baby though casey
affleck doesn't seem to be in a
talkative mood while out and about in
l.a
keeping things vague on his big absence
my brother how come that your brother's
waiting today just quick question
your fans want to know everybody wants
to know that how come you know that your
brother's wedding
how come you're not at your brother's
wedding today
you fell asleep
okay you fell asleep you said
today is your brother's big day
you're an athlete
casey you
et's reached out to the actor's reps
about why he decided to opt out of the
wedding festivities
when it comes to benzex jennifer garner
she reportedly kept things low-key
while seemingly in a good mood at sam's
club over the weekend in south
charleston west virginia
garner and affleck were married for 13
years until their split in 2018
share three children violet seraphina
and samuel
they're funny and smart and you know i
think they're awesome while jen was in
virginia the kiddos were in georgia to
watch their fathers say i do
jen garner has been supportive of ben
and his rekindle romance along with
jlo's ex-husband mark anthony
the father of her 13 year old twins max
and emmy and it just turned out to be
something really magical a source tells
e.t quote mark anthony and jen and ben
and jen garner also get along relatively
well and share special places in each
other's hearts
absolutely
cheers to benefit 2.0
[Music]